Good afternoon.
Good afternoon, internet.
We're gonna try and
implode this drum today.
Veritasium did a cool video where
you heat up some water inside,
you turn it all to steam, you bung it up,
you cool it down,
and the pressure causes it
just to implode on itself.
I made a barbecue thingy here earlier.
Sort of half assed it, didn't
bother doing the rest of it.
We're gonna heat it up on there,
with some water in,
and then move it to here
and then cool it down in
some cold water and a hose
and hopefully we get the implosion effect.
We're gonna try to film the implosion
at two and a half
thousand frames a second.
And see if it looks all
graceful and crinkly.
Are you confident about this experiment,
think it will work?
I recon we're gonna try.
I don't know, I'll be
surprised if it worked.
Really?
I'll be surprised if we can do it.
Yeah.
With our lack of experience.
Looks like it's kicking off
some right steam there, Dan.
Yeah, it is, it's working right.
I think we're ready.
Okay.
You know what to do.
Whoa.
Aw, Damn, it's gone, this side.
Oh!
Go, .
Alright, Dan, we appear to have suffered
a partial implosion.
We did.
Hold your hand there
where that's gonna be again.
Oh.
It's exploding now.
And you've bummed it already?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
Oh, God!
Ow!
Whoo!
Oh, it did it!
Yeah.
It totally did it.
Ooh!
That happened really quickly.
You can see, there, the water
hasn't even started moving--
You can see how quickly it went
because the water sat on top.
Yeah.
It just got whipped out from under it.
That is mental.
It's a really cool experiment.
That guy agrees.
Well, that was really
impressive, actually,
that was pretty cool.
It's actually
a very consistent experiment.
I don't think we left
it cooking long enough
the first time we tried it,
so we got like, the partial.
Yeah, it sort of flumed on the sides.
Like, flume a bit.
And then in the end, it
had to gunk, eventually.
So, it flumed in, and then it gunked.
Yeah, so it was a flume, gunk type thing.
Yeah.
But we got the gunk in slow-mo.
It was a good gunk.
We might revisit this one day,
maybe just try and be better at it.
You know, just try to
be better scientists.
And in the meantime, follow us on Twitter,
subscribe to The Slow Mo Guys,
and just watch a bunch of
slow-mo videos on YouTube.
We make a lot of them.
See you later.
See you later, then.
As you can see, there,
Dan and I learned a lot about pressure.
And on the subject of learning things,
a lot of people are going
back to school this week,
or already have gone back to school.
But it is very important to remember
that around the world, in
under privileged areas,
a lot of people aren't
going back to school.
So we're all asking for you
to donate to Comic Relief
to help the kids in underprivileged areas
try and get a decent education.
So if you can, please
donate to Comic Relief
using the link on the screen.
Any amount helps the greater goal.
Thanks.